pauline puisque je vous ai dans ma ligne
de mire c'est un sujet pour vous car où
on va parler de sexe maintenant vous
écouter on dit souvent on dit on dit
parfois même que ceux qui en parlent le
plus
en font le moins oui et bien l'adage
serait visiblement vrai puisque les
français seraient de très gros menteur
concernant leurs performances sexuelles
c'est ce que nous explique bourdin
direct vous avec les français ont la
réputation d'être parmi les plus
pratiquants du monde quand vous demandez
aux hommes et aux femmes d'estimer le
nombre de relations qu'ils peuvent avoir
en un mois ils répondent 21-21 une
relation c'est à dire cinq jours sur
sept on ne vous leur demandez en
revanche de prendre un calendrier et de
noter scrupuleusement à chaque fois
qu'ils ont également un rapport là le
chiffre tombe à cinq au népal et cela
nous est sommé de fierté voilà les
mexicains parle de 29 rapport par mois
alors qu'en réalité ces quatre les
indiens 27 alors que ces trois
t'en vas tu as déjà menti à dubrulle a
fait croire qu'il l'avait déjà fait lors
du tome avait décidé bon goût ça bouge
plus non alors est ce que vous êtes
étonnés quand même par ce type de
sondage ne fait que les français
seraient assez vantard et qu'en fait
c'est quoi ces 500 fois par mois au lieu
quand même le delta il est on est
d'accord avec pas moi c'est pas beaucoup
bah ça fait une fois par semaine sinon
sur les gens moi c'est énorme
[Rires]
jean michel est épuisée par mois ça
passe donc franchement je me situerais
au milieu de ces deux chiffres
c est plus de 20 ans franchement une
fois par semaine je trouve que c'est
trop peu et vente une fois par mois
franchement je trouve que c'est beaucoup
trop
chez moi et je vous rappelle ma théorie
sur le piment à la chaire a effecté est
d'accord on le coût pour qu'il se sente
bien
pour que le désir revienne et que la
libido soit toujours présent là qu elle
est donc 21 par mois non c'est beaucoup
de tabous et c'est évidemment un donnant
ces clubs là le bon chiffre très à peu
près entre 10 et 15 déc trouve que c'est
bien c'est votre vie moi je dis toujours
moi parce que je pars en les gens jaloux
oh là là mais le sexy pas possible eh
ben on lui a posé la question au dos je
reste assez circonspects non pas
circoncis un sujet avec au ddc titre
c'est pas incompatible en effet parce
que cette étude un peu flou on sait pas
si c'est avec la même femme plusieurs
benon là on va écouter avec dominique
blanc n'a pas tout on n'a pas tout vous
dire les heures travaillées
vous estimez que cinq fois par heure
j'aime j'allais dire par mois c'est
c'est un homme qui travaille beaucoup
trop et c'est et juste vous nous posez
la question mais vous patrol alors
on ne sait pas que du nombre de fois
vous faites l'amour parce mais je ne
comprends pas votre question nouveau nos
hantises et j'ai eu un petit cigognes
qui est venu qu'à déposer un bébé sur ma
première venue un grand garçon m
[Applaudissements]
je connais votre compagnon je me
rappelle est alors attention bien on a
posé la question de téléspectateurs soit
faite vous l'amour plusieurs fois par
semaine une fois par semaine au moins
d'une fois par semaine
alors ceux qui emportent c'est tous les
menteurs qui disent plusieurs suites 19%
pour une fois par semaine et moins d'une
fois par semaine en ils sont assez
honnête quand même à moins d'une fois
par semaine à 41 %
on bosse mais on bosse on doit être où
on déclaré non mais c'est moins bon si
vous foncez c'est important si vous
voulez je vous remplace de trois fois
ses coups et je vois merci merci de
proposer vos services vous êtes des
macbook